YouTube prankster Marc Mitra has been
convicted of a hate crime after posting
a video of his dog doing a Nazi salute
to phrases including the horrific gas
the Jews apparently and understandably
this rather puerile joke caused gross
offence but however unfunny the joke was
is irrelevant surely to the principle of
free speech defending speech you agree
with isn't defending free speech at all
it's only defending yourself defending
free speech only applies when you
disagree now viewers have every right to
be offended by my speech but no one has
a right to insist that I don't offend
them else we may as well just say
nothing at all criminalizing a hitherto
unknown comedian for his unfunny joke is
something we'd expect from the Nazis
themselves
remember Basil Fawlty or allo allo this
charge should be ashamed of his chilling
precedent how do we Lampoon Isis for
example if by imitating them were to be
accused of glorifying terrorism the
correct response to a joke that you
don't like is simply not to laugh at it
and just as a warning that some viewers
might find the language used in this
debate uncomfortable you see you've got
me puzzled here because a couple weeks
ago on this show I was actually
defending free speech and you were
telling me that you made it perfectly
clear to me Thome in no uncertain terms
of free speech can turn into hatred what
a quotes you said was you said language
used in newspaper that Stokes of
anti-muslim sentiments wrote will create
an atmosphere that breeds anti-muslim
violence now if we must not aid the
hatred of Muslims why is it okay to aid
the hatred of Jews I don't know whether
you saw this guy this well I think a dog
I don't know whether you saw did you
watch this guy's video did you at least
let me finish you you've you want to
finish let me finish at least 30 times
he said gas the Jews gas the Jews he was
laughing you don't think that will
incite hatred or violence against
Muslims and say no it's exactly what he
said I have the code to do I'm sure it's
exactly what you said you said
inflammatory language even if it's legal
creates an atmosphere where violent
can happen so you don't think shouting
gasps the Jews 30 times is inflammatory
language okay so I honestly don't know
where to go with this I've just won an
award for challenging anti-semitism I
write for a Jewish newspaper I'm
actually going to Geneva to receive
another award for challenging
anti-semitism by the Jewish community I
don't want to make it about
anti-semitism and my views because
they're quite well-known I do want to
make it about the difference between
hate speech and comedy if I may because
the two examples you're giving whether
it's challenging anti-muslim bigotry or
it's indeed challenging is the mist
extremism which I'm better known for
doing by the way
challenging extremism that comes from my
own communities hate speech is when
you're inciting violence specifically I
don't see it the same as comedy and
that's the debate I think we should be
hold on let me let me let me explain
because in comedy when cracking jokes
it's the intention of the comedian that
matters and it's the it's the intention
as stated at the beginning of this very
video that we're discussing where the
comedian himself says I'm doing this
joke because I wish to upset my
girlfriend because her dog show yes the
Jews explained what he said and then we
can discuss it he says because this park
is the cutest dog that we have it's a
cutest thing we can think of and turning
it into an r/t the uncute esteem that he
says on the video is something I'm doing
to as a joke to offend the Nazis and to
wind up my girlfriend now that during
the Nazis a Hungarian did the same thing
and the Nazis accused this Hungarian man
of training his dog to do a Nazi salute
what they did they then prosecuted this
Hungarian man they did exactly the same
thing because they were offended that
they were being compared to dogs and so
actually with comedy it comes down to
intention and interpretation and what
I'm suggesting I hear what you're saying
and I'm a long wait going down the road
if you were running oh I don't know a
French satirical magazine would you
knowingly put on the cover a cartoon of
Mohammed knowing how it is so again
during that time and actually two years
before the Charlie Hebdo attacks I
posted a picture of the Prophet Mohammed
and I said I'm not offended and that
Muslims should grow up and grow a spine
and then the Charlie Hebdo attacks
happened and I was very vocal about
defending the magazine
and still remain facilities all right to
deliberately I'm just asking not saying
you're wrong but it is all right to
deliberately cause offence yes because
because you've got every right to take
offense right um but at the end of the
day you've got no right to insist that I
don't offend you and the difference
between inciting hatred is when you
what's called targeted hate when you
when your speech is targeting
specifically and inciting violence in
then I will yield the floor
someone once did some pretty foul gags
about Katie Price aka Jordan's son who
has I mean really vile guys you know the
solution hitted no you see permitting
what we're talking about is a criminal
offense I don't like those jokes I don't
like this joke we're talking about
sending something a criminal conviction
sending somebody to jail that's why I
think we're mixing topical gags about
the disabled legally you can do them I
will object to them as why I don't find
this joke funny
why are you now dancing on the head of a
pin Margie the ramifications in your
criminal defense joke which is very
different saying I don't like the joke
that's not dancing on out of a pin
that's the same as a debate actually the
Carroll raised the other time when when
I said look the difference between
inciting anti-muslim bigotry you should
be legally entitled to say what you want
as long as you're not inciting violence
but be careful in outside the context
that it here's what the actual judge had
to say on the issue and why he wrote the
way he did in my view it is a reasonable
conclusion that the video is grossly
offensive the description of the video
as humorous is no magic wand
this Court has taken the freedom of
expression into consideration but the
right to freedom of expression also
comes with responsibility and I have to
say Majid when you first raised the
topic I agreed with you but I hadn't
seen the video and then when I saw the
video I thought at some point we have
got all the line you know why
we hear what the comedian had to say
yeah actually you can come in here's
what the comedian himself had to say I'm
not an anti-semite and I made this video
to tough my girlfriend that is the
lateral reality of the situation but if
the court wants to completely reject
that reality and substitute it with its
own well unfortunately that's not up to
me you know if I were to be lampooning
Isis I would be imitating some of the
language and some of their slogans but
it's clear if especially if I at the
beginning of the video say I'm now
lampooning them that I'm actually it's a
comedy sketch whether you find it funny
I try to write about this last week and
in the end my newspaper decided not to
run my piece because I was saying much
what majid said obviously not as still
on YouTube there has been viewed three
million times I don't think there have
been any complaints from it it's no
users complain no users have complained
it's a joke not against the Jews but
against the Nazis context is all when it
comes to telling a joke and we are now
allowing our course to decide what's
funny or not which essentially means the
death of comedy
if this man goes to prison for
essentially telling a joke it's not just
the death of comedy it really means we
need a first moment in this country we
need to have a law defending free speech
otherwise nobody will say anything
because they can breach something they
can be accused of hate speech
by a judge who doesn't get the joke it's
really serious a couple of fences or
dogs a couple of things you know we need
to be aware there we people from the
British Jewish community were watching
now who feel very very so we must offer
them respect and you're right but with
with the right to free speech comes the
responsibility and this old line you can
shout fire in a crowded cinema but it's
a pretty irresponsible thing to do so we
have the rights but we have to be
responsible how they're discharged and I
would argue that I'm with June I think
that bloke went too far much as the one
involving know
I'm sorry if you were in it I mean if
you were to early film if you're in a
film in a comedy film you shouted fire
in a cinema and then the comedy film
showed the reaction that's what we're
talking about we're not talking out in
real life shouting fire in a cinema
where people will get trampled you see
there was a very good example I remember
the movie came out some years ago which
said it's going to Lampoon I think Isis
fighters almost in tears it's called
three lines and everybody went raving
then in fact I don't have you've seen it
but it's if it's a it's a it's an
absolute comedy about thank the Lord how
often they are enabled that is what
comedy a comedy comedy shouldn't be
criminal I was going to say one last
thing on this was I said it was a
Hungarian they did it to the Nazis was
actually finished man okay just to
clarify that but look that's bad comedy
shouldn't be penalized right to say it
nobody thinks he should be sent to
prison or get a criminal record for a
bad comedy you have to find this as
comedy
lots of Jewish people in the current
climate will not think this is comedy